yeah so in terms of choosing our clients
there were a few criteria that we're
looking for other than effect that they
had a disability you had to have been
pretty stable so it wasn't going to be
fluctuating too much over the semester
and that is to kind of make the design
constraints a little bit more simple for
the students apart from a stable
disability they I think what we loved
about the clients this semester is
motivation to educate our students and
so um having that intrinsic quality of
being an educator was important for us
you had to be able to articulate their
challenges really well for the students
and be able to be patient with the
students because they're all learning
through this process and they might not
get the design process right the first
time but having clients that were
adventurous willing to try out new
things with the students that was very
important the third piece was purely
logistical so our students are going to
want to interact with their clients as
many times as possible over the semester
so we made sure that they were all
accessible from MIT I think within a
one-hour radius of MIT so I think one
thing you'll find in a disability
community is that once you talk to one
person it's such a tight community that
what travel was really fast and so we
had a little bit of a lucky break and
that we contacted the Cambridge
commission for people with disabilities
and Kate Thurman there helped us to send
out an email to the entire community of
people disabilities and then I'm pretty
sure we got about 50 emails if not more
from people who are interested in being
quiet and so we either try to talk to
them over the phone or visit them in
person to get to know them you know I
think to be to be very honest so in
terms of having clients involved in the
class participating in lectures in some
of the labs and also certainly being
very much a part of the design process
so be very honest it's it's a tricky
decision and something that we decided
to try this year and sort of to see what
what would happen I think a big part of
it is really kind of the user centered
or participatory design nature of the
class that you really we really want
students to understand the person that
they're working with understand their
challenges and realities in all the
contexts that their that they're in in
their home or when they're out in the in
the in Boston or you know even at MIT as
well so I think one big part of it was
to really give students the opportunity
to interact more with their clients and
really get their feedback quickly and
work on the design process together I
think the other part is we really try to
see our clients as collaborators with
the students as grace mentioned really i
think clients are most attuned to their
own needs and their own ideas or their
own their own needs in terms of what
assistive technologies might be useful
so they really are able to give kind of
the best possible feedback so having
them embedded or participating in the
class I think is was really important
and really a valuable experiment or
experienced to try so my name is as a
key right it was an experiment this year
we had lab assistants in the class this
year who was students last year and they
did not have clients in your class and
when we first made a decision to say
okay clients can be in our class and in
our lab assistants or how that were
going that was going and they raised
quite a few concerns but at the end of
the day we said you know what people
just need to our students just need to
learn how
go shoot these situations as part of the
learning process is an important thing
to be able to work around these kinds of
situations and that's fine the other
thing that I I don't like it's when we
talk about I'm disability or we teach
students how to talk about disability as
if people with disabilities that is like
outside group though we are what kind of
observing from the inside um and I don't
think I think it's a much more inclusive
way of teaching if we can bring in
people with disabilities to talk about
their own experiences with these
students instead of as just showing
slides and saying these are the terms
that you should use when you're talking
to people with disabilities you know it
means so much more coming from the
people of disabilities themselves in
terms of how we set up the students in
the clients and coordinated at
interaction so let me start right from
the beginning we meet with the clients
once we know we've selected them we I
believe we selected about 15 clients at
the start of the class and we told them
there is a potential that you will get
to work with students this semester and
this is the expectation that you are
able to give two to three hours each
week to meet with our students from this
date to this date then we went to our
students and gave them a whole list of
the clients and we didn't describe the
clients in too much detail other than
you know some potential challenges that
they had that students might want to
work on then we let the students decide
for themselves which clients they were
interested in working with based on your
skill sets and based on your interests
we matched up students with the clients
and so at the end of it we actually only
had 11 student teams and so 11 clients
do what matched so we had to tell the
remaining four clients I'm sorry you
know you were not met for this semester
but we really appreciate your
availability um so right after we
finished that matching we basically sent
an email to the clients and the students
introduced them tote them you know this
is how you can contact each other and
then for the very first client meeting
for the students their mentors went
along with the students to just you know
make sure the interaction went well
something that says Professor teller
kind of established in a class I think
probably for the first first year or so
was this student client contract where
it says where the student will say you
know we are going to work with you as
well as we can these are the
expectations that you can hold us to and
then the clients also have expectations
that the students can hold them to and
they both sign off with it and it's just
a way of facilitating the initial
interactions so that both sides are able
to talk about what they will be able to
do and what they won't be able to do and
managing those expectations is a huge
part of any kind relationship no I think
I think yeah this this contract and
really setting the expectations setting
the stage for students to succeed and
clients to really understand what the
process is about and how they can be
most valuable to the students in terms
of giving feedback and sharing their
ideas openly and really knowing that
they're kind of an equal partner in in
the in the team's project is really
really key I think grace did a lot of
great work this year in terms of the
curation part we had a chance to talk to
a lot of potential clients and really
figure out what would be kind of the
best match for the expected make up of
students in our class you know as greats
mentioned clients who are adventurous
and interested in learning and
interested in teaching and open-minded
have some assistive technology idea in
mind I think this is a big part sort of
the
the front part of the class that can be
really valuable to help set it up for
success for the semester